and i think that's that's up to you you
could ask
them you could ask
how are you good how are you i'm doing
great
pleasure to speak with you today big fan
of your work been following you for a
while oblivion is like one of my
favorite movies ever
and black widow was great i loved you
as taskmaster um i didn't see the twist
coming
at all and i'll go ahead and just ask
the big question because everybody's
wondering david arbour is talking about
wanting to return
elena seemed pretty clear to be set up
to return
now there's rumors about taskmaster
returning to the mcu you returning to
play her
what are the chances that we see her
return
and what would you want from that story
good bad more more dialogue kind of your
our chance to pitch the writers here on
what you'd like to say
i you know i don't know if my character
will return i think that's
uh that's up to you you could ask them
and but uh of course you know would i be
delighted to return
of course um it's i had so much fun
playing the character
she's so cool so strong
and but at the same time so damaged and
suffering and there's like all sorts of
spikes to her
and uh that is there's so much to
explore
um of course i would like to keep
exploring that
yeah that would be great to see because
like you said it does seem like there is
just so much left to tell
of her story you know very strong
character but so vulnerable at the same
time because of her past
and it's kind of crazy to think that
we're sitting here talking about
the future of taskmaster for when you
have to keep this a secret for
for two years that's crazy to think
because
as somebody whose job it is to look into
movies and figure out
exactly what's going on i had i had no
idea this was such a big twist to me it
was truly a surprise
how did you go about keeping this a
secret for two years that had to be
crazy
i just yeah i just couldn't speak about
it and when people met sometimes people
would mention
like they would talk about the movie and
i had to pretend like
oh yeah yeah that's a cool movie yeah
yeah oh it's coming out soon yeah
yeah yeah and some some people i think
in some
films someone said ah but like when are
you gonna be part of that isn't that
cool
this is the one this is what you should
be doing you should be doing marvel and
i was like
yeah no wouldn't that be great yeah
but i couldn't have already done it so
it was fun and my mom just discovered it
two days ago so
there we go i kept really yeah well what
do you want to
see my mother out of all people i knew
she should
not know because i said please keep it a
secret forget about it
realize it you know she just gets so
excited like she will never know it's
not even her fault so
i know people like i know some people
you can't say just yeah
no i understand that completely
that's so funny your own mother um
that's great that must have been
really really hard especially with the
delay but yeah congratulations for uh
keeping it such a big surprise you know
so much of your scenes without the mask
on
are heavily reliant on eye contact
um you know body language not so much on
dialogue uh was that hard for you
how did you approach kind of this
character in that way
well you know it's actually interesting
that the character is introduced in that
way
um because it's almost it's not hard
it's almost
uh it's almost uh logical
that someone who has been manipulated
um for so many years and who's
controlled
and who can be herself uh someone who is
basically imprisoned
within you know uh
mentally emotionally and physically
imprisoned
someone who has gone through so much
suffering
uh she wouldn't exactly be very chatty
when she
when she suddenly appears i mean there's
so much confusion
in herself she herself is
she has she's gonna have to figure out
who what the hell has happened to her
and why it happened to her it's almost
like when she's one-on-one
she's gonna have to you know come back
to her senses
and right um do you know what i mean so
it's
yeah it's it's it made sense that
everything actually does come through
the eyes and through the look
and it's that confusion and horror and
then later
realization where there's that moment
realization of
um of wow wait
like the spell has just what happened
who am i you know right
right you women come head to head and
there is this acknowledgement of each
other and
and acceptance of each other and
suddenly
realization of like you know what have i
been doing
uh and why and that's not me well i
personally
very very much look forward to hopefully
seeing the rest of that story played out
uh play out
but thank you so much olga such a
pleasure to talk to you and i loved you
as taskmaster
thank you very much